>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> If Jerry Pinkney
hasn't illustrated it,
it probably isn't worth
illustrating.
[ Applause ]
Among his more than 100
books, there are such classics
as "The Little Match Girl," "The
Ugly Duckling," "Uncle Remus,"
"Rikki-Tikki-Tavi," "Tales from
Africa," "Myths from Greece,"
"Little Red Riding
Hood," "Aesop's Fables."
So sumptious are Jerry's
illustrations, so perfectly in tune
with the subject matter,
that it sometimes seems
as if the source material
was written only
to be illustrated by him.
You haven't read "Aesop's Fables"
until you've seen Jerry's
interpretation of them.
In fact, just the other day --
I don't know if you heard
about these tigers being
discovered really high
up in the Himalaya 9,000,
13,000 feet up or something.
When I heard that story,
I thought to myslef,
"That would make a great
Jerry Pinkney book."
He's a native of Philadelphia.
He took an interest in
drawing at a very early age.
All right, Philly.
He has illustrated, as I said, more
than 100 books, started in 1964,
and along the way, he's been
honored multiple times of Caldecott
and Coretta Scott King
awards and honors.
He's taught illustration,
conducted workshops at universities
across the country, created art
for the US Postal Service's
Black Heritage stamps,
and had more than 20
one-man retrospective shows
at major US venues.
He also created the art work for
the 2005 National Festival poster.
So please give a warm welcome
to the incredible Jerry Pinkney.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
I was here last year, remember?
It was raining like crazy?
Yeah. So I asked the person upstairs
to -- but he went overboard.
Little too hot.
Little too hot, but thank
you, guys, for staying.
My new book is "The Three
Little Kittens," which is out,
and you guys can get
a chance, actually,
the opportunity to get it today.
But this comes out next month.
And it's always interesting
for me because I've done
so many books, to talk
about the book.
I will do that, but I think
there are other, probably,
stories that are connected to what
and how and the choice of a book
that I want to share
with you this afternoon.
So I want to talk about two
stories, and then I want to talk
about the inspiriation for
this book, but before I get
to that point, you're
going to have to help me
because there's some point
I'm going to ask you to sing
"The Three Little Kittens," okay?
So you don't have to -- I
want you to think about it.
now, I would join you, but
I have a terrible voice,
so I'm going to lean on you.
Okay. But the first story really has
a lot to do with how did I happen
to get to this point where
there's 100 books under my belt,
and where did that come from?
And I know there's a lot of kids
and children in this audience,
and also parents that might be
interested in it because I grew
up in a family that --
there were no artists.
There were no artists in the
family or in the neighborhood.
I grew in the Germantown
section of Philadelphia,
and I loved to draw as a kid.
I drew all the time.
And my parents were great.
They always supplied me even
with the simplest of materials.
My father -- my father
was a jack of all trades,
and he did wallpaper
hanging, and he did painting.
He would bring home
scraps of wallpaper.
And I would turn the pattern of the
wallpaper, you know, against a floor
or a desk, and I would
draw on the other side.
So I was constantly drawing and
always had a sketchbook with me.
So at the age of 12,
I took my first job.
And I was selling newspapers at a
very busy intersection on the corner
of Germantown and Shelton Avenue.
And I would take a
drawing pad with me,
and inbetween selling newspapers,
I would draw people waiting
for the bus or the trolley.
There was a department
store, Raoul's,
when they would change
the window displays,
I would treat the changing window
displays like changing still life.
And so I had this sketchbook, and
you know, I'm not sure what kind
of job I did with selling
newspapers, but my boss was okay.
Matt was great.
So one day, one of my
customers is John Liney.
He's a professional artist
of a strip called "Henry."
And he invites me up to his studio.
He sees me.
He takes note, and he asked
if I would share my sketches.
I do. He looked through
my sketchbook,
and he invited me up to his studio.
Now, remember I said no
artists in the family.
It's my first introduction
to an artist.
I go to visit John, beautiful day,
third floor, big space, sketches,
projects on the walls, in the center
of that space, a drawing table
with a taberet with a whole array
of brushes and pencils and inks
and watercolors and all kinds of
size pads, which you can imagine
for a young boy, 12,
experiences this wonderous space,
this magical space, but
really, what impressed me most
and what struck me most
about that day was here,
here was a grown man doing the
very same thing that I loved doing.
What was that?
What do I love doing?
What did I tell you I loved doing.
Drawing. And this is the
way he made his living.
This is the way he
[inaudible] for his family.
Now, did I know that,
when leaving that day,
that some day that Jerry Pinkney
would grow up and be an artist?
I'm not sure about that, but I know
tha the possiblity, the possibilty,
the seed was planted that day.
And that was a pretty special day,
and we remained friends
for many, many years.
The other story, which also
deals with Germantown section,
was I grew up in this sort of
small, deadend street of rowhouses,
and there was six of us
kids and mom and dad.
It was a five-room house with
a bathroom without a sink.
So -- and we didn't have pets.
There were no pets.
A few of our neighbors had pets,
and I always wondered
why we didn't have pets.
Now I know.
There was no space.
We couldn't cram anything
else that was living in there.
So I didn't really
understand about pets,
I sort of shied away from animals.
We went to the zoo and that kind
of thing, but -- until an adult.
And as an adult, your
kids what pets.
And I think we still kept it
at bay until we had a neighbor
who had a litter of kittens,
and we went over to see them.
And it was in a cardboard
box, and they were all inside.
And there was one striking kitten,
and it looked as if someone took,
like, bleach or something.
It was spotted in an interesting
way of browns and blacks
and light grays and whatnot.
And we called her "Clorox."
So Clorox -- and Clorox was a great
cat to start with because she --
well, she just didn't want to
be bothered, I mean, at all.
So I mean, you could sneak
in a pet here and there,
but -- so she was very easy.
And then we got hooked,
and we found Brillo.
Brillo we found he, for some reason,
found him outside of our home.
We were in Boston at the time,
and we started, you know,
we started giving him
little bowls of milk,
and finally he didn't go
away, and we took Brillo in.
Brillo was the opposite.
I don't think he was the
brightest cat, but he was funny,
and he was always in trouble.
And he always made
me feel like a hero
because I was always
saving him from something.
He could climb a tree;
he couldn't get down.
He'd chase the birds, and
the birds would beat him up.
It was constant, and we felt so
badly, but it was really wonderful.
And then there was Shadow.
Shadow was over an
overhang when we moved
into Croton, and he
only had one eye.
We got him down, patched him
up, and we had several cats.
And the last one, the last
cat's name was "Pumpkin,"
and it was our granddaughter's cat.
And she moved into an apartment
that didn't allow pets.
So we took in Pumpkin.
Now, I have to ask
you guys a question.
What color do you think pumpkin was?
>> Orange.
>> Yes. Orange.
Any other?
Yes? What color?
>> Black.
>> How did you know?
>> [Inaudible].
>> His name was Black.
She wasn't planted in
the audience by the way.
Pumpkin was black for
some reason or another.
So there's always been this
wonderful history of cats.
And we don't have a cat
now because I travel a lot,
and we lost the last one, but
just in this whole experience
of "The Three Little Kittens," you
get a sense that when my life calms
down a bit, I'm going to be
on the search for a kitten.
I mean, there fabulous animals,
and I think was always this
attachment to finding a stray.
That was something
very important there.
Now, inspiration for the
"Three Little Kittens."
Well, my wife, Gloria Jean, who's an
author, oftentimes suggests projects
for me, and she suggested
"The Three Little Kittens."
Now, I had trouble with the three
little kittens eating the pie
with the mittens, okay?
I struggled with that piece
a little bit, and then I knew
that it was a nonsense rhyme, so
things didn't really always have
to add up, but I was still
trying to make sense of it.
Now, I have a great
granddaugher, Zion, and Zion,
I've been observing her for
awhile now, and she's my teacher.
And why and how things
don't always have
to match up to have a good time.
And she has this wonderful
imagination,
and I also love the idea, the
way she plays with things.
I remember once, we were going out
for a walk, and it was kind of brisk
that day, and she's
pushing her stroller,
and you could tell
her hands were cold.
So I thought there were
gloves in her pocket.
It turns out there's only one.
So she puts the one
on, and she's warm.
And the other -- it's like the
other hand is covered as well.
so there's always this kind
of wonderful kind of energy
and excitement about
things just being.
She loves two different shoes,
you know, go on the right foot,
but a different shoe,
one right and a left.
And you could see her
playing with things.
And so you see that in
"The Three Little Kittens."
You see a kind of exploring and
trying to engage and connect
with the same kind of
imaginations that kids have.
How do you teach kids?
You feed them where they are.
And so I've tried to do that.
Now, okay, all right, okay.
You've thought about "The
Three Little Kittens."
Well, here's what happened.
Now, we're going to sing it first.
Okay, I'll start the tempo count of
[ Singing ]
The three little kittens that lost
their mittens and then began to cry,
"Oh mother dear, oh mother
dear, see here, see here,
our mittens we have lost."
"What, lost your mittens?
You naughty kittens?
Then you shall have no pie.
Then you shall have no pie."
And then it goes
[ Singing ]
"Meow, meow, meow, then
you shall have no pie."
The three little kittens,
they washed their mittens --
No, they bit their mittens.
What did --
>> They found their mittens.
[ Singing ]
>> They found their
mittens and then they began
to cry, "Meow, meow, meow."
The three kittens put on their
mittens and began to eat the pie.
Meow, meow, meow.
The three little kittens,
you naughty kittens,
you soiled your mittens, and
you shall have some pie."
Okay, all right, you
guys aren't doing great.
I'm -- now I changed -- I
changed it a little bit.
That's why I'm kind of struggling.
Also, I didn't want to do what
I just did and embarrass myself.
But it's over now, and I'm fine.
I'm fine. So anyway,
here's what I did.
So it's a sparse little
text, right, in this book.
And I'm always sorry for you guys
all the way over the end there.
Hi. We begin to understand
a little bit more
about the kittens and
their families.
We know that they would
like to go out to play.
And I love -- oh, gosh, you
guys did you buy these copies
because you can share them
with -- well, that's okay.
anyway, these kittens are
really curious about the world,
and you know cats are, okay?
So they're curious, and
we actually see the mother
in the process knitting,
so we know where --
now we know where the
mittens came from.
The mother knits.
None of cats did.
So they want to go out and play.
And there you see, I'm setting
you up to the fact that going
out to play, they're
going to need mittens.
All right?
So here's where I try to take these
classic folktales, in this case,
a nonsense rhyme, and expand
on it because what I do is,
when the kittens lose their
mittens, it's three spreads
where the kittens are
out in nature, playing,
and you actually see
them lose their mittens.
And again, it's -- I watched --
if my great granddaughter
is doing something,
and something distracts
here, whatever she was doing,
that's gone, and she moves on.
so the kittens actually --
and so the children can actually
follow the kittens while they --
when they lose their mittens.
So it's a number of spreads,
and they return home,
of course, without the mittens.
Now, here's the other part
that I hope to engage you with,
and that is that the kittens now
return to find their mittens.
So this is the circle.
And so they return to the
same place where, of course,
they've lost their mittens.
And so now the children can
now follow in the process
of finding the mittens, okay.
All right?
And they all find them.
So someone suggests
it's a counting book,
but my granddaughter was counting
past three a long time ago,
so I'm not sure.
But it is this process of discovery.
Okay, they find the mittens.
They return, and of course,
they -- how's the sound on this?
Okay? And they begin to eat the pie.
And it goes through a lot
of differernt spreads,
and it finally -- oh, of
course, they wash their mittens.
Now, you can't see this,
but I have to tell you,
these kittens aren't just
voluntarily doing that chore.
One is playing, the --
you know how kids --
you ever ask kids to do something?
And they -- well, this is the --
my son, Brian, the illustrator,
says that these kittens
are stand-ins
for my great granddaughter.
And we see them hang
the mittens up to dry,
and mother is walking home
with a basket of apples.
Now, the first pie was blueberry,
and this spread, which
I expand on again.
The kittens say, "Can we
go out to play again?"
All right?
And the endpapers, they do with
now not only mittens, but caps.
And we find -- though
it's hard to see --
one of the kittens
has lost their cap.
So we go full circle.
So here's the other thing
about the singing part.
I -- by the way, you guys were
pretty good, and especially you.
You were really into it.
anyway, so when I would talk to
people about the why of doing
"The Three Little Kittens,"
they would always --
adults would always sing it.
So I said, "Oh, that's interesting.
In order to bring it back to
mind, they would sing it."
so I went to my editor, Lori Hornick
[assumed spelling] and we rewrote,
adapted some of the text, so I
said, "Why don't we make it singable
so that you could sing it like
you could sing the rhyme?"
So we came to that point,
and I said, "Okay, then,
wouldn't it be great if
people knew about it.
So here's the bonus.
Here's the bonus.
If you take off the
jacket, we had music scored
for "The Three Little Kittens."
>> Yay.
>> Yeah.
[ Applause ]
And there's really, really
terrific, wonderful story.
I was signing, and of course,
you don't come upon this.
there's a little note
on the copywrite page,
but most people go
past the copywrite.
So I mentioned to a woman.
She was excited about buying
it and whatnot, and I said,
"I want to just show you something."
And I took of this -- the
cover, and I showed it.
And she said, "Oh,
and I play the piano."
And she got so excited
about this whole thing.
And it's kind of, in a way, it's --
for me, I think the physical book
is really incredibly important.
so it's a way of building
in to the physical,
traditional book something else.
Something that the child can
experience or you can experience.
It's not interactive because it
takes effort in a different kind
of way, but it's still engaging a
child, especially the children today
that have so many bells
and whistles around them.
So that's my effort
to sort of do that.
Now, they just -- I hold up a
card, like in the boxing ring,
that there's only a
certain amount of time left.
And I think I'd like
to devote that time
to perhaps a question
or two, if we could.
So there are microphones and
-- so get your questions ready.
All right, who's got
the first question?
[ Silence ]
Who's got the first question?
Okay, yes?
>> I want to become an author.
Did you have any advice for me?
>> Okay, in becoming an author,
write and write and rewrite,
and write the things that you know,
or things that you dream about.
the main thing is you want to
put something down on paper
so that you can look
at it and then know how
to take that and make it better.
But you can't think about writing.
You can't think about illustrating.
You got to actually do it.
it's in the act of doing.
>> Okay.
>> Yes, good question.
Who's next?
We got to go left from
right -- right to left.
>> Um, what's your favorite
book that you've written?
>> Pardon me?
>> What's your favorite
book that you've written?
>> Would I read a book?
>> That you've written?
>> Oh, that've I've written?
A famous one?
>> Favorite.
>> A favorite one that I've written.
I -- you know, I think -- you
know, what's really special
about having a new book
published is the excitement
that surrounds that book.
So the question, I'm going
to answer that today,
it really is "The Three
Little Kittens"
because that's the
one that's really most
on my mind and my heart right now.
Okay. I feel like this
thing is a tail.
>> When I was four, I had a little
movie that's called "Repunzel"
and it's a Barbie movie,
and it's about a girl
who escapes her evil stepmother --
>> Right.
>> -- By drawing.
>> Um-hum.
And the question?
>> Can you give me
advice to be a drawer?
>> Can I do what?
Help me out [inaudible].
>> Give me advice -- give me
the advice to be a drawer.
>> Oh, can I give you
advice to being a drawer.
I think that microphone
is feeding back.
I -- you know, I mentioned
that I had carried a sketchbook
when I was your age, and I think,
still, that's the best way to do it
because if you carry a little
sketch book around with you,
you can jot down ideas
when they come to you.
Or if you see something you want
to kind of record, it'll help you,
but if you don't have
the tools around you,
you're never going to do it.
so make sure you have
the tools around.
Make sure mom and dad
gets you a sketchbook.
>> What inspired you to
write "The Talking Egss?"
>> Actually I illustrated
"The Talking Eggs."
>> Oh, yeah, that's right.
>> I collaborated with
the author, Bob San Souci.
Now, and there's something
special about "The Talking Eggs."
Does it kind of parallel
"Cinderella?"
Yeah, it's sort of a take
off from "Cinderella."
By the way, I love
"The Talking Eggs."
It's a special book.
You know the pony in that book?
>> Um-hum.
>> My Uncle Osby [assumed
spelling] had a pony
with a cart, and I used to ride it.
Yes?
>> How much drawing do
you practice every day?
>> I draw as much as I can
because I have the projects.
But it's how much time do I
take in practicing drawing.
This is a very good question because
most often, if I'm not travelling,
I still go to a drawing
workshop on Monday evenings.
Why? Because I can still
improve my drawing,
so I draw as much as possible.
Yes?
>> Were you ever teased as a child
because you were into drawing,
and what would you say to
children who are into maybe writing
or drawing or acting or singing,
who aren't necessarily into sports,
who get teased as little
kids for that?
>> Yeah, I think that you have
to kind of combat that with
as much exposure as you can
to people with like minds.
You take them to the theater or
to the museum so that they build
up a sort of protection from the
fact that what they want to do,
that is important to them, may
not be important to others.
And that's always going to be there.
If you're true to your
goal, and it's different,
that's going to be part of it.
So find yourself surrounded by
the things that support you.
Yes?
>> Do you have a special and unique
way to personalize your drawings?
>> Do I have special --
>> And unique ways to
personalize your drawings?
>> Oh, special ways to
personalize my drawing.
There is a way of describing
it and saying its style.
There's a style that
you find with the I --
more important than the way I draw
things, but the way I see things.
That determines what I draw.
It's a kind of finding a
unique way of seeing something
and then finding these
skills to record that.
So now, I do things in my work
that are, I think, unique.
I tend to hide things in it.
But basically, it's about
learning to see differently.
Yes?
>> When you draw -- when
you were a drawer as a kid,
did you teach yourself
how to get better at it,
or did you just draw a lot?
>> I did, and I think a lot
had to do with really wanting,
an overwhelming sense that
this was important to me,
and I don't remember that
there was effort involved.
I -- because I loved
every minute of it.
And I was fortunate enough,
also, to be encouraged,
but I loved every minute of it.
And I didn't have any
great expectations.
I didn't know I was going
to become an artist.
It was something that
made me feel better
about myself, and it centered me.
>> Thank you.
>> Hi there.
>> Hi.
>> I wanted to ask, who were some
of your favorite illustrators
growing up, or even now?
>> Oh, I came from Pennsylvania.
N.C. Wyeth and Howard Pyle,
that whole school of recording.
My work isn't necessarily
representational,
but it had that feel
and that quality.
So you can imagine, you
know, what N.C. Wyeth --
and as a kid, every kid
wants something bigger
than life, and he painted that way.
>> Hi. I'd like to know as a
children's book illustrator,
how long does it take you to
actually do a book, I mean,
with sketchs, and you know,
corrections, and painting.
>> Yeah, I -- how long does
it take me to finish a book?
I ask for, like, six months.
Some books will strecth into nine,
very few that I come in on time,
but -- and there are some where I
let it grow on me to the point where
"The Old African" took me two years.
I was very fortunate to have
a publisher who understood.
So that's what you want.
You want to invest in
something that you love so much,
it doesn't matter how
much time it takes,
and that's where you want to be.
And I'm blessed.
I'm in that place now,
which publishers understand.
Yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> Over time.
I know what that means.
Couldn't be a zero with a
minus or something like that?
I want to say one thing to you guys.
thank you for hanging
around for this.
this is an amazing,
amazing festival.
It's the 10th anniversary, so
let's all say happy anniversary.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.